spider-man has been featured in numerous
movies and hundreds of tv episodes and
many actors have gotten a chance to
portray the iconic webslinger here's a
look at the major versions of spider-man
from tv and movies as well as the actors
who played them ranked from worst to
best
it isn't nicholas hammond's fault that
barely anybody remembers the short-lived
amazing spider-man tv show from the late
1970s he just didn't have much to work
with with no super villains and only
several familiar faces from the comics
hammond's take on the character feels
less like a superhero and more like a
regular guy in a red jumpsuit the
amazing spider-man aired on cbs
alongside the incredible hulk but while
the latter show turned out to be a hit
that defined the character for years
amazing spider-man would only ever be a
footnote in spider-man's long history
spider-man unlimited was an attempt to
extend the 90s animated series past its
sell-by date by recasting spider-man and
sending him to a darker alternate earth
reno romano does very little to make the
character his own instead making an
effort to sound exactly like his
predecessor christopher daniel barnes
his costume inspired by the spider-man
2099 comics certainly looks cool but
would probably have fit better in an
actual spider-man 2099 cartoon
adaptation
paul souls as spider-man sounds the way
people in the 1960s expected a superhero
to sound which means his voice is a
little deeper than the depictions of
peter parker we see today souls does his
best getting into the role but it's
clear that this first spider-man cartoon
which ran from 1967 to 1970 isn't very
interested in characterization this
version of spider-man is perhaps best
remembered today as the star of many
animated
the 1981 spider-man animated series
isn't bad by any means the animation is
solid for the time and it brings in a
lot of villains from the comics who'd
never gotten tv time before ted schwartz
does an admirable job bringing this
iteration of spider-man to life bringing
more individuality to the role than most
had before him the strange thing about
this show is that it was immediately
overshadowed by a different spider-man
cartoon spider-man and his amazing
friends which premiered the same day
features more marvel heroes and a
stronger lead performance by dan
gilvazan the two series also feature
nearly identical animation styles and
character designs which can make for a
disorienting viewing experience
unfortunately for shorts this is a
series that many have chosen to forget
boy some days it hardly pays to be a
lovable superhero
spider-man's very first live-action
appearance was on the electric company a
1970s educational series that ran on pbs
this spider-man doesn't talk and never
appears out of costume but his simple
adventures and easily described actions
are the perfect vehicle for teaching
kids basic language and math skills the
show also has a lot of fun bringing the
comic book aesthetic to life with danny
segren often framed by comic book panels
and speaking with the aid of word
balloons it's a trick to get children to
read of course but it does so with
plenty of fun and personality
admittedly this is kind of an odd one in
1990 spider-man starred in a short psa
about child abuse that was distributed
to schools and libraries there's no
green goblin or mysterio here just a
father who hits his daughter and a group
of kids who turn to spider-man for help
spider-man tells them that violence is
never the answer and recommends a
hotline to call spider-man doesn't have
a whole lot to do here since the
spotlight is on the kids but he's well
portrayed by veteran voice actor greg
snagoff credited here as gregory snow
he's reminiscent of the 80s animated
spider-man and more importantly has a
warmth to him when interacting with
troubled children he comes off as an
adult you can trust which is both
perfect for this cartoon and exactly
what spider-man should be
given time and a spider-verse sequel or
two this spider-man of the future could
potentially move much higher on this
list after all spider-man 2099 aka
geneticist miguel o'hara has a cult
following all his own on top of that
he's voiced by the incredibly popular
oscar isaac of star wars and ex machina
fame the problem of course is that he's
barely in spider-man into the
spider-verse at all appearing only in
the film's after credits sequence it's
fun to see him reenact a famous meme
from the 60s spider-man show but it's an
inauspicious beginning for miguel we can
only hope that he'll have more of a
presence in spider-verse 2.
two big things are distracting about
2003's spider-man the new animated
series a more mature take on the comics
that aired on mtv of all places the
first is the animation which combines 2d
cartooning with 3d computer modeling in
an incredibly awkward way the second is
that every time neil patrick harris's
version of spider-man talks it's hard
not to imagine doogie hauser or barney
stinson under the red and blue suit
harris wasn't a bad choice for
spider-man at the time but it's
difficult to accept him as peter parker
today when his voice has become so
recognizable as a musical tv star out of
all the spider-man cartoons since the
60s this one has probably aged the worst
everybody loves miles morales the modern
teenage spider-man created by brian
michael bendis and sarah pikelli in 2011
for marvel's now defunct ultimate comics
line even when the ultimate line ended
miles and his supporting cast managed to
survive thanks to his popularity and the
unique flavor he adds to the spider-man
franchise unfortunately bringing him
into the 2017 spider-man animated series
just didn't work that well rather than
originating from an alternate dimension
this version of miles played by naji
jeter is nothing more than a school
friend of peter parker's who gains his
own powers and dons his own costume when
he first goes into action he's portrayed
as a sloppy and overly enthusiastic hero
who initially does a very bad job peter
has to act as a coach and mentor despite
being somewhere around miles age the
whole storyline feels shoehorned in and
robs miles morales of much of what makes
him such a compelling character
gwen stacy has been a part of
spider-man's story in the comics since
1965 but it's only recently she's gained
super powers of her own known to the
world as spider-woman and to her friends
as spider-gwen this web slinger has been
a fan favorite since she first donned
the white and pink suit in 2014. the
gwen stacy of the 2017 spider-man series
however suffers from a similar problem
as miles morales she's a school mate of
peters rather than the main spider
person of her own world unfortunately
this take on gwen seems less like her
own superhero and more like just another
spidey sidekick perhaps this show chose
to avoid introducing a multiverse
because into the spider verse was
already in production but both spider
gwen and miles morales feel like cheap
imitations of their spider-verse
incarnations as a result still veteran
voice actor laura bailey does her best
with the material she's
given while lego productions are known
for drawing heavily from their source
material 2015's avengers reassembled
actually came out before spider-man's
first mcu appearance in captain america
civil war with no tom holland's
performance to base lego peter parker
off of this plastic take on spidey is a
bit generic compared to his counterparts
that aren't made out of bricks
still ben diskin gives it his all in the
role as he continues to do in the role
of flash thompson in the 2017 spider-man
series once the mcu established their
own spider-man however the lego one had
to evolve a bit to keep up
cole howard is an experienced and
talented young voice actor and his work
in 2020's lego marvel avengers climate
conundrum certainly fits the character
of peter parker however it's fairly
clear that howard got the part because
his spider-man voice sounds very much
like tom hollands howard spider-man
comes off as a bit younger and a lot
sillier than holland's live-action
performance but the similarity is still
unmistakable for lego marvel avengers
which is basically the movies but
sillier and aimed at younger audiences
cole howard is doing exactly what's
needed for the part
we're ranking these three spider kids
from the disney junior series as a group
rather than individually because frankly
these versions just aren't quite
distinctive enough to warrant their own
entries spidey and his amazing friends
is aimed at preschool kids which means
all the sharp corners are pretty much
sanded off of course that doesn't mean
it's a bad show it's pleasant and
likable enough with each episode
featuring two short adventures in which
the spidey team faced similarly aged
down super villains and learn lessons
about sharing and so forth the villains
include a really great female doc ock
who's basically a little girl version of
catherine han from into the spider-verse
give it up doc ock you can't handle
spidey team
but can you handle the might of
gigantic squishy
as far as characterization goes however
there's just not much going on in a show
like this the spidey team is voiced by
actual kids and talented ones that which
does add to the show's unique energy as
kids shows go this one certainly could
be a lot worse but it's not where adult
fans are going in search of great takes
on spider-man and his friends
the very first spider-man introduced in
spider-man into the spider-verse is the
peter parker of miles morales earth
voiced by the absurdly charismatic chris
pine he's the big time hero of new york
and basically the perfect spider-man he
even has blonde hair unlike any other
version of peter parker to mark him as a
literal golden boy the problem however
is that a flawless spider-man doesn't
feel like a spider-man at all the whole
point of the character is that he's a
flawed hero and nothing ever seems to go
right for him this spider-man isn't in
the movie to be a character of his own
though he is there to provide an
idealized image that conflicts with the
inexperienced miles and the slevenly
peter b parker plus making him the
perfect superhero makes the tragedy of
his death that much greater especially
as he leaves behind a legacy that miles
must try and live up to
although the original spider-man noir
comic where this version of peter parker
originated is quite a serious affair the
version of him that appears into the
spider-verse is essentially a one note
joke character still thanks to plenty of
great lines and a flawless voice
performance by the peerless nicholas
cage he's an extremely funny joke
character sometimes i let matches burn
down to my fingertips just to feel
something anything
not only does spiderman noir sound like
a perfectly hard-boiled detective he
also looks extremely striking rendered
entirely in black and white halftone in
a colorful world if he comes back in
spider-verse 2 it might be fun to get to
know him a little better but even if we
don't we're still incredibly glad to
have seen him in action
the 1978 japanese spider-man live-action
tv series has developed a cult following
in the us even though it's never been
officially released here it was produced
by the toei company who later created
mighty morphin power rangers and they
infused spider-man with a similar
tokusatsu vibe shinjitoro plays
spider-man's face and voice while
hirofumi koga does much of the
performing inside the spider protector
suit in this series spider-man is a
motorcycle driver named takuya yamashiro
who gets his spider powers from a super
bracelet from the planet spider mostly
he does what american spider-man does
climbing walls spinning webs and so
forth being a true tokusatsu hero he
also has a race car and a giant robot
named leah pardon the show is a lot of
fun and toto and koga both do a great
job but it drifts pretty far from
spider-man as we understand him these
days its primary appeal is definitely
the camp factor
a far more streamlined and spidery mech
than leah pardon penny parker's spider
isn't nearly as big but it has a lot
more personality it's also co-piloted by
an actual spider that has a psychic link
with young penny played by kamiko glenn
together they're the spider heroes of a
new york in the year 3145 that exists
somewhere out in the spider-verse
penny and spider are inspired by
japanese mega anime like neon genesis
evangelion and gundam
although penny doesn't get too much
character development she's a great
example of just how far a spider hero
can get from the standard template we've
seen time and time again she also
provides some emotional punch in the
final battle as spider sacrifices
himself to save penny fortunately she's
able to save her spider friend from
inside the mech so hopefully they'll be
able to rebuild upon returning to their
own dimension
of all the secondary spider people in
spider-man into the spider-verse
spider-ham is by far the silliest that
works for him though in fact it's kind
of the whole point spider-ham is
essentially a looney tunes character
down to his silhouette resembling porky
pig he's even mastered cartoon physics
making him one of the most unpredictable
fighters the spider-verse has to offer
some kind of silly cartoon
spider-ham's on-screen appearance is a
departure from the original comic book
version of the character who starred in
1985's peter porker the spectacular
spider-ham there he's a little more
serious working alongside other animal
avengers like captain americat and iron
mouse in into the spiderverse however
the silliness of spiderham makes for
some of the movie's funniest moments
largely thanks to a fantastic voice
performance from comedian john mulaney
by 2017 it was pretty established in the
minds of fans what a teenage peter
parker should sound like and robbie
damond nails it aside from that however
not much about this version of the
character feels fresh or new the 2017
spider-man is a solid engaging animated
series but it's all kind of been done
already it's fun to see spider-man team
up with other marvel heroes like iron
man black widow and the hulk but story
lines featuring multiple web-slinging
characters lack the spark that made them
memorable in into the spider-verse
sometimes it feels like the most daring
part of this spider-man incarnation is
the way his belt doesn't quite fully
connect on the front of his costume
still if you're looking for a solid
spider-man voice performance you could
do a lot worse than robbie damond
back in the early days of 21st century
superhero movies years before the mcu
toby maguire got the job done he got in
great physical shape for sam raimi
spider-man and its sequels but kept the
charmingly goofy face that made peter
parker a relatable figure for audiences
of all ages while he never quite seems
like a kid the way an early career
spider-man should he's young looking
enough to sell a teenage performance
even though he was in his late 20s when
production began in the emotional scenes
maguire's always a little over the top
but he makes up for it with fun quips
and killer dance moves he's definitely a
solid spider-man but nothing to write
home about
ultimate spider-man was controversial
from day one for one thing it replaced
the popular spectacular spider-man
series which ended due to character
rights issues after disney purchased
marvel in 2009 some fans grew even more
irritated when drake bell of drake and
josh fame was hired to voice the title
character expecting that this version of
the character would be geared for a
younger less mature audience however if
you ignore any bad publicity bell is
actually a pretty great animated
spider-man he has a high capacity for
silliness and fun as spider-man always
should but he also comes through in the
darker moments that require a more
emotional peter parker although this
iteration of spider-man may not have
gotten the same rave reviews that
spectacular spider-man's peter parker
did bell certainly does the job
the biggest problem with andrew garfield
in the amazing spider-man is that he
always looked too old for the part
garfield may have made a good adult
peter parker if the script wrote him as
such but a nearly 30 year old man in the
role of a bullied highschooler is a hard
sell to the point that it almost never
stops being distracting even still
garfield's take on the wall crawler has
plenty going for him he looks good in
the suit his comedic timing is on point
and his chemistry with emma stone's gwen
stacy makes for one of the best romantic
storylines that spider-man media has to
offer garfield is a fine transitional
spider-man but not exactly the type that
would have worked best in the marvel
cinematic universe
for a lot of millennials christopher
daniel barnes was the definitive voice
of spider-man during their childhood
having played the role on fox kids from
1994 to 1998. while this spider-man
series has aged a little awkwardly it
was the first spider-man tv show to draw
on the comics story lines in a nuanced
way introducing characters like venom
and even the punisher to saturday
morning viewers this series saves the
origin story for the theme song and
begins with peter parker already in
college and freelancing for the daily
bugle within that context barnes is
perfect in the part balancing the jokes
and the emotional baggage that are both
so central to spider-man with its solid
characterization and season-long story
arcs this show is one of the best takes
on grown-up peter parker that you can
find
for those a little older dan gilvazhan
is the saturday morning spider-man of
choice he voices the wall-crawling hero
on spider-man and his amazing friends a
show that brought the marvel universe to
life from 1981 until 1983. gilvazan was
a mainstay of 1980s animation also known
for his roles as bumblebee and
transformers and cooler in pound puppies
his spider-man has the lightness that
earlier versions of the character had
been missing while still seeming more
grounded than his goofier friend iceman
played by frank welker this cartoon may
seem pretty silly by today's standards
but this was the first time spider-man
really felt like the spider-man we all
know today and that's worth something
despite failing to gain momentum in the
2017 cartoon spider gwen thankfully got
her chance to shine as one of the
numerous spider people featured in into
the spider verse as the one and only
spider hero of her world this
incarnation of gwen stacy was motivated
to protect new york city by the death of
her best friend peter parker before
getting sucked into an extra dimensional
wormhole despite rocky first impressions
gwen becomes a close friend to miles and
despite a hint of romantic tension
there's nothing too forced or mushy to
distract from daring heroics as far as
spider people go spider gwen is one of
the strongest while miles is new to the
game and peter b's glory days are behind
him gwen is in the prime of her
superhero career she's graceful strong
and always helpful in a pinch hayley
steinfeld gives a standout voice
performance as gwen with the perfect mix
of youthful enthusiasm and effortless
ability she's not exactly spider-man but
as far as spider people go she's one of
the best
peter parker has always been a bit of a
sad sack but peter b parker from into
the spider-verse takes it to a whole new
level as the hero of new york for over
two decades the years have taken their
toll on peter as he approaches 40 he
finds himself broke separated from his
wife mary jane and gaining a noticeable
punch he's the natural end point of
peter parker's bad luck and the exact
opposite of the spider-man that miles
morales grew up seeing however once he
realizes it's up to him to mentor young
miles in the art of web slinging he
rediscovers the hero he's always been
deep down this is a take on peter parker
that's never quite been seen before and
wouldn't work in most contexts but in
spider-man into the spider-verse he's
perfect hilarious and ultimately
touching jake johnson star of tv's new
girl is the perfect choice to voice this
version of the character and gives a
surprisingly nuanced performance he may
not be the best or the most powerful
spider-man but he might just be the most
endearing one
spectacular spider-man is considered by
many to be the perfect 21st century
spider-man cartoon and one that ended
far too soon for frustrating reasons it
ran for two seasons from 2008 to 2009
and was being considered for a third
when disney bought marvel and reacquired
the television rights to spider-man
leaving this sony produced series in
legal limbo unable to continue
spectacular spider-man takes peter
parker back to high school with a unique
new design aesthetic that fits perfectly
voice actor josh keaton plays this
youthful spider-man with the earnestness
of a kid trying to do his best and he
couldn't have done a better job it's
just a shame we couldn't have seen more
of him
despite being the third live-action
spidey inside of a decade tom holland's
take on peter parker was a fan favorite
from the moment the world first saw him
steal the vibranium shield in the
trailer for captain america civil war
unlike maguire and garfield however
holland has the authentic look and feel
of an anxious teenager who's got himself
way in over his head the genuine
youthfulness and naivete of holland's
portrayal of peter parker contrasts
perfectly with the adult heroes of the
marvel cinematic universe especially
iron man tony stark's mentorship of
peter adds serious emotional depth to
both characters in a way no other
version of spider-man has done while
spider-man is a character defined by
tragedy no other actors have captured
the raw emotion of peter parker quite as
effectively as holland has as we've
witnessed in one of the most emotionally
devastating moments the mcu has to offer
i don't want to go i don't want to go
start please please
as far as the solo efforts go holland's
peter parker is an awkward yet
charismatic young hero who's still
finding his place in the world trying to
balance the life of an honor student
with the life of a superhero even though
he's constantly having to clean up his
own mistakes wherever he goes he comes
across as inexperienced without ever
seeming incompetent and by the end of
far from home he's become a hero that
tony stark would be proud of all of this
is topped off with a technological
marvel of a costume which gives
spider-man the opportunity to be more
expressive than any other live-action
version of him had been before details
like this combined with tom holland's
stellar performance make for the best
peter parker outside of the comics
themselves
with apologies to all versions of peter
parker miles morales is the spider-man
of the future he's energetic he's
artistic and as the son of a black
father and a puerto rican mother he
represents the changing face of america
in the best possible light as someone
who grew up in spider-man's friendly
neighborhood miles finds himself with
some pretty big shoes to fill after the
death of his world's peter parker
however with some help from his family
and a half dozen other spider people
miles is able to figure out his
abilities and become the hero his city
needs it's more than just his background
that makes miles as spider-man unique
however his invisibility and venom
strike abilities eventually make him a
fearsome foe for baddies like kingpin
despite all the spider people who appear
throughout into the spider-verse it's
miles's story first and foremost and
just as it's the best spider-man movie
ever made it shows how miles has the
potential to be the best spider-man it
certainly helps that he's voiced by
shamiq moore from the get down who
embodies the character flawlessly it's
only a matter of time until we see miles
in live action whether he's replacing
peter parker or working alongside him
miles morales is the future of
spider-man and the future is bright
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel characters are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]